you know in his career against
cincinnati in five starts so this will
be start number six
and he struck him out with a breaking
ball and went straight down
let's hit this deep center back goes
delido to shields junior and he runs it
down
runner goes swinging and a miss he
struck him up got him to go fish really
tested the patience of suarez
3-2 pitch
blew him away with a 98 mile per hour
fastball and that's the way the indians
first inning starts here tonight jose
ramirez switched hitter
smacked it deep right field back as
castellanos goodbye and the indians
strike first
on the third home run of the year by
jose ramirez he did not try to fool him
with a change up he challenged him with
a fastball and jose ramirez is not one
to uh
lose on a fastball challenge beyond the
point of no return swing and a miss
home run in the inning what was that
yes
in the series over six swung on and miss
carrasco strikes out kyle farmer that's
the beginning of a maturation of a
hitter when you can lay off those
pitchers pitches
and he was blown away by the 97 heat
on ball two strikes on mercado
and three straight strikeouts carrying
over to the final out of the first
inning for luis he has four on the night
15 pitches in this inning the strikeout
on the chain jump
he tried to hold up but he went around
and the tag is applied
swing and a miss he went fishing for the
changeup or the slider excuse me he
looks like university of georgia georgia
tech both after him hard can't leave mom
out
all american track and field ball and
two strikes
on mercado he struck out his first time
off castillo looking for number eight
and he's got it
[Applause]
tried to hold up but he went around and
that's a half dozen case for carresco
jose ramirez will step in
his home run back in the first inning
the difference in this one swung on line
drive down the right field line fair
ball this one's headed toward the corner
on the run is hernandez he's flying the
third being waved around the relay throw
will not come home into third goes
ramirez scoring is hernandez and jose
ramirez with the big night makes it
two-nothing tribe
ripped into right field and the indians
add to their lead as francisco lindor
delivers a two-out rbi single and it's
three to nothing cleveland
and now friend neil check sling bottom a
nice play down on one knee he'll handle
it himself from that'll in the inning
joey's made a couple nice plays tonight
and
move up to third base as suarez draws
the walk
and that brings up jesse winker
representing the tying run
generous strike to winker at the bottom
of the zone and
it is a ball and two strikes winker
really didn't like that call
he turned around immediately and looked
at jerry mills and said that ball's down
the 97th pitch of the night
[Applause]
struck him out looking oh you didn't
like that earlier one i called a strike
how do you like me now oh man
i don't know if the whole plate up fire
meals thought that he went around on the
swing because if that was a call third
strike
[Music]
that is not a good call so jesse winker
was ejected as was manager david bell
so they both got the he vote
he walked him how do you like that
another run home for cleveland as
hernandez scores ramirez to third lindor
down to second give carlos santana
his third rbi on the year
[Applause]
base is loaded one out
reyes
in the hole low in two
and he muscles one into right field for
a base hit that'll score ramirez here
comes lindor castiano's throw to the
play and he is safe and it's a two-run
single for reyes and the indians have
taken command to this game and they lead
it six to nothing
nine pitches in the sixth and he
has walked his second straight hitter
with the bases loaded and that will
hasten his exit from the game the
indians have scored five times
continues pitching and there's a ball
laced into the right field corner by
cesar hernandez this might clear him
scoring is santana bo taylor here comes
the shields he's in standing it's a
three-run double for cesar hernandez and
what an explosion for the tribe here in
the seventh jose ramirez batting
right-handed has had a big night [ __ ]
a swing in a high drive deep left field
headed for the bleachers and it is
gone
[Music]
a two-run home run to left by jose
ramirez and for the second time this
year
jose has hit home runs from each side of
the plate in the same game
and tonight two home runs a triple four
rbis and the indians have a
[Laughter]
ramirez there's one hernandez turns a
double play to end the ball game
and the indians take the ohio cup
winning three out of four on the year